alternate worlds are another science
fiction staple
perhaps the earliest example is the
twilight zone episode the parallel
in which an astronaut returns home to
find himself in an alternate universe
slightly different from his own most
famously
the star trek episode mirror mirror
introduced us
to the mirror universe in which everyone
is evil
including beardo spock there's the
alternate world of jj abrams show fringe
where the 911 attacks on the twin towers
never happened
and the amazon original series the man
in the high castle based on the philip k
dick novel it imagines an alternate
universe where the nazis in japan
won world war ii indeed fictional
depictions of alternate universes
often imagine what the world would be
like
had major events gone differently but
sometimes
it's not just one alternate universe
it's a multiverse there's the jet lee
sci-fi martial arts film the one where
jet li tracks down
alternate universe versions of himself
or the tv show sliders where people
slide between one alternate universe to
another
in the futurama episode the farnsworth
parabox
professor farnsworth creates alternate
universes and keeps them
in boxes and rick from rick and morty
has a gun that opens up a portal to
almost any universe you can imagine
and then of course there is the
multiverse from the episode of star trek
the next generation
i ask you to watch for this lecture
parallels which
seems to be an homage to the
aforementioned twilight zone episode
the parallel where lieutenant wharf
returns home to the enterprise
to find himself in an alternate universe
and then is continually
pushed into a new universe every time he
gets near his crewmate
jordi laforge more on that episode a
little bit later
first we need to clarify our terms
we might wonder for example why we use
the term universe to refer
to these alternate worlds doesn't
universe just mean
all that exists so that there is by
definition
just one universe one collection of all
that exists
and that collection may or may not
contain what we might call
many worlds well sure
that is one way to define universe but
in science fiction
as we've just seen and in science itself
the term is
often used differently what definition
could
capture the relevant concept well we
might say that a universe is simply a
collection of matter
that is closed off from outside causal
interaction but by that definition it
would be impossible to
travel from one universe to the other
the travel
would be a would be a causal interaction
but although such travel may never
actually happen
i i wouldn't say that such travel is
logically impossible that it
can't be conceived it's conceived in
sci-fi all the time
and as we shall see some scientists do
think
interaction between universes is
possible
a better definition of universe would
seem to be a
space-time continuum and all the
entities for example
all the matter it contains this would
keep us from identifying some
subset of matter in our universe as a
universe itself
but would also seem to allow for the
possibility
of other universes and travel between
them
we could probably tweak the definition
further but
i think this should do for our current
purposes
the most common way to understand what a
multiverse is
is in terms of alternate dimensions
consider the block world view of time we
considered last lecture
it's the collection of all the
three-dimensional moments in time of our
universe
set into a four-dimensional block
to envision a multiverse just think of a
collection of such blocks
stacked up in the fifth dimension
according to this theory
our universe lives on a membrane or
brain
among many other universes that also
live on brains
in what is called the bulk when you hear
people talk about parallel universes
this is usually what people are talking
about it's like the multiverse is a
giant clothed book and there's a
universe on every page
[Music]
but are there any actual reasons to
suppose alternate universes could exist
yes in fact it just might be the next
logical conclusion after all humans
first thought that ours was the only
planet then we discovered others
ours was thought to be the only solar
system and the only galaxy
then we discovered others should we
expect it to be any different
with our universe i don't see why in
fact
relativity is completely consistent with
the existence of parallel universes
and physicist paul steinhardt
and neil turock have suggested a version
of string theory
that also supports it now some might
object to be appealing to scientific
theories
since this is a philosophy course but
first
they're fascinating so we're going to
talk about them regardless
two scientific evidence is often
relevant to philosophic arguments
indeed science is just an offshoot of
philosophy
all the early scientists were
philosophers and science was made
possible because of discoveries
by philosophers in fact science was
first called
natural philosophy so it's all fair game
and three most of what we are going to
be talking about
deals with the implications of
scientific theories which means
what we're doing is called philosophy of
science
but speaking of science there are other
ways of conceiving of the multiverse and
how it came about besides
simply thinking of universes stacked up
in a fifth dimension
consider this it's widely acknowledged
that our universe began when a
singularity exploded with a big bang
and many physicists like ed tryon
suspect that the singularity which was
the source of the big bang
was the result of a quantum fluctuation
in the vacuum that existed
prior to our universe how is that
possible
well simply put not even vacuums
are empty they contain no matter sure
but they are still filled with quantum
activity
and such quantum activity can randomly
generate matter
we've actually observed this on small
scales but give a
large enough vacuum a long enough time
and a large amount of matter
could be produced such matter would
briefly be contained in a
tiny dense hot point that explodes
causing that matter to expand out
something very much like this is what
generated our universe
now we used to wonder whether gravity
would eventually
pull all the matter of our universe back
in the big crunch
it was called but we now know that the
force of gravity is not strong enough to
do this
and that indeed the expansion of the
universe
is accelerating what many scientists
now expect is that the universe will
eventually end in what's called
a heat death all entropy will stop
every atom will decay and will be back
down
to a vacuum but that vacuum will still
be teeming
with quantum activity according to the
work of physicists sean carroll
and jennifer chen given long enough that
could produce another big bang indeed
this could have already happened many
times over
and be going to happen many times over
this idea was illustrated beautifully in
the futurama episode
the late philip j fry professor
farnsworth invents a stationary
time machine that can only go forward in
time
after he fry and bender go too far
forward and
can't find a future time with a
backwards time machine
they decide to fast forward to the end
of the universe
you know to watch the spectacle but
after it ends
another big bang happens and a new
universe forms around them
and history unfolds just as it did
before
they stop to kill hitler and then
proceed to the year
in this new universe equivalent to the
one that they left
well actually they overshoot that too
the first time they have to
bring it back around but they eventually
get there and when they do
they land on their counterparts thus
killing them
because this third universe is about 10
feet
lower than the original now in reality
history wouldn't necessarily
repeat itself more on that later but it
seems that we should describe each one
of these new collections of matter
as a new universe each one of these
consecutive collections of matter
would be in its own space-time continuum
if so
ours is just the latest in an infinite
series of universes
and all of reality consists of what we
might call
an oscillating multiverse
at this point one might argue that an
oscillating multiverse wouldn't
really count as a multiverse because all
of the universes aren't happening
at the same time to really be a
multiverse
the events of each universe have to all
be happening simultaneously
like they like they are on the
previously discussed view that has
multiple universes all stacked up in the
bulk
but as we learned last lecture according
to relativity
simultaneity is relative to reference
frame
so only two events in the same universe
can be simultaneous and even then only
in certain reference frames
it's actually meaningless to think of
two events in two different universes in
the bulk
as happening at the same time just like
words on two different pages of a book
can't be on the same line indeed
since on both models each universe would
be
contained in its own space-time
continuum
the only difference between a bulk
multiverse and a
oscillating multiverse is how we picture
it in our mind
the former universes are stacked
vertically
the latter are laid out horizontally but
both kinds of multiverse are
simply made up of collections of matter
contained in their own space-time
continuum
[Music]
what's more an oscillating multiverse is
not that different from alexander v
lincoln's conception
of the multiverse based on the theory of
inflation
inflation is a period of super fast
expansion of space
that can be slowed locally in specific
places
by specific instances of quantum
activity
this is how quantum fluctuations can
produce a big bang
when a fluctuation slows the inflation
the energy that drove inflation spills
over
igniting a hot fireball of particles and
radiation
a big bang but inflation continues
elsewhere
where that quantum activity had no
effect this continually creates
more and more space for the same thing
to happen again
somewhere else some other quantum
activity slows inflation
and boom another expanding bubble
and since inflation is eternal this
would happen
an infinite amount of times it's not
clear whether we should picture such
universes as being
stacked or laid out consecutively but
regardless
it seems we should rightly call it a
multiverse
now what would the universes in a
multiverse
look like would they like in futurama
contain all the same events happening
over and over again
or would their histories be different
like in star trek
according to lincoln since there's an
infinite amount
inevitably an unlimited number of
universes of all possible types will be
formed
so if he's right they'd be different but
if other universes are governed by the
same physical laws as ours
and granted some might not be but of
those that are
one might suspect that they will all
turn out just like ours
because they started in the same way too
same starting conditions
plus the same laws yields the same
results
but recall from the lecture on free will
in the matrix
that determinism is false all
events aren't governed by the laws of
physics
on the micro quantum level some events
happen randomly and
without cause so everything won't be
exactly the same
even in universes governed by the same
laws
but as we also learned in that lecture
quantum randomness gets averaged out on
the larger
macro scale that's why physical laws
have predictive power
so it still could be that universes with
the same laws and starting positions
would all be the same on the macro level
it would depend on whether the outcome
of random quantum events could
ever determine what happens in the macro
world
and it seems that they could
take for example schrodinger's cat
schrodinger imagined a cat in a box next
to a vial of poison
poison that would be released only if a
geiger counter detected the decay of a
radioactive
atom whether the atom decays is a micro
quantum event determined randomly
and so whether the cat lives a macro
event
is also determined randomly
so if you had two universes identical in
every way
that both contain cats in these
circumstances
it could very well be that one cat lives
in one universe
another one dies in the other universe
now that wouldn't be a big difference
but if the outcome of quantum events
have an effect on the macro scale
often enough two universes with the same
starting point
and the same laws could end up being
considerably different
how could this happen well suppose that
the outcome of the physical processes in
the brain
that generate decisions are dictated by
the outcome of
quantum events if a quantum particle in
your brain does one thing you'll do x
and if it does the other you'll do y if
so
two universes could be exactly the same
up to the point
that you make a decision but then
diverge with you doing x in one universe
and y in the other if you compile
all the different ways that everyone's
decisions could go
and all the other choices that they
could present people
you would have a wide array of different
universes
some only slightly different others
vastly
so and this is where we return to
parallels
because that seems to be exactly what it
depicts
upon his return to the starship
enterprise lieutenant wharf
starts to notice strange things the
cakey cuts at the party was chocolate
but then suddenly is vanilla captain
picard couldn't make it to the party
then he's there as the episode continues
the differences become more extreme
control panels aren't like he remembers
the bridge's configuration is completely
different
data has blue rather than yellow eyes
captain picard is dead and
wharf is the first officer he and
counselor troy are
married and have kids the list goes on
what's happened on his way back to the
ship in a shuttle craft he encountered a
quantum fissure in the space-time
continuum that opened the barrier
between quantum universes
and put wharf in a state of quantum flux
this caused him to slip between
universes
trading places with his counterparts now
that's mostly just
technobabble to drive the plot but
what's interesting
is that the differences between the
universes are
dictated by the differences in choices
people make
which seem to be dictated randomly by
the outcome of quantum events
as commander data explains for any event
there is an infinite number of possible
outcomes
our choices determine which outcome will
follow but there is a theory in quantum
physics
that all possibilities in other words
all choices that can happen
do happen in alternate quantum realities
in fact this explanation seems to invoke
an
actual interpretation of quantum
mechanics which suggests that a
multiverse exists
that for every way that a quantum event
could turn out
there is a universe in which it turns
out that way
if our decisions actually are dictated
by random quantum events
the kind of multiverse that this episode
of star trek describes
could be accurate to properly understand
this interpretation of quantum mechanics
however
will take some explaining
[Music]
what quantum mechanics tells us is that
until they are measured
subatomic particles like electrons and
photons
don't determinately have certain
properties like
location or momentum they do have other
properties like mass and charge
but they are not in any particular
location or moving
with any specific momentum they are in
what is called
a super position
they can be described with mathematical
functions called
wave functions but these wave functions
suggest
that the particles have multiple
seemingly contradictory
properties at once an electron could be
we might say
twenty percent here and forty percent
there
these wave functions can be used to
accurately predict the particle's
behavior
when measured twenty percent of the time
such an electron will be here and
40 of the time it will be there but it's
not in any particular location
until it is measured and the wave
function
collapses and to be clear it's not that
we can't figure out
what location or momentum such particles
have until they are measured
as i explained in exploring metaphysics
we have shown experimentally
that such properties are not had by such
particles
until they are measured in short
they exist as waves until they are
measured
at which point they become a particle
the strangeness of all this has made
some scientists adopt what's called
a non-realist interpretation of quantum
mechanics
in philosophy of science realists are
those who suggest that a theory's
ability to make accurate predictions
justifies the conclusion that the theory
is true
that it describes reality for example
in chemistry the theory that chemical
reactions are the result of
interactions between atoms and molecules
is seen by realist to be good reason to
think that
atoms and molecules exist and interact
in the way described by
chemical reaction equations the
non-realist on the other hand
will say that the predictive power of a
theory isn't
a reason to think that it describes
reality
after all other theories could be
imagined that make the same predictions
a theory's predictive power means that
it is an accurate instrument for making
predictions
and that's it the view is also called
instrumentalism for example einstein's
relativistic equations treat
space-time as an actual substance in
which objects are
situated a substance that is warped and
curved by
mass and makes objects behave in certain
ways
but an instrumentalist would argue that
this doesn't mean that space-time is
really a
substance it just means that pretending
that it is is a useful way to make
predictions
about the behavior of objects indeed
it seems that this is what einstein
thought about relativity
because of the weird things that quantum
mechanics suggests about the nature of
subatomic particles
things that don't even seem to make
sense like it's 20 here
and 40 there many scientists want to say
the same thing about quantum mechanics
quantum wave functions don't tell us
what the particles are really like
they say they're just an instrument for
making accurate predictions
we shouldn't even wonder what they
really mean
as physicist in david merman once
summarized the view
shut up and calculate the problem with
taking this approach with quantum
mechanics or
relativity for that matter is
essentially twofold
first scientists generally don't do this
with anything else
a pilot's assumption that the world is
round lets him successfully arrive at
his destination
you'd think i was crazy if i said this
wasn't a good reason to think the world
was round
that assuming the world was round was
just a useful
navigational instrument indeed modern
scientists
championed science's ability to describe
reality
because of its predictive success it's
completely ad hoc and arbitrary
to suddenly abandon this notion because
quantum mechanics or relativity
tells you something you don't like
second
the argument for instrumentalism is
predicated on a mistake
the fact that multiple theories can make
the same predictions
doesn't mean that there is no reason to
favor one theory over the other
as we have seen in previous lectures the
criteria of adequacy and fruitfulness
simplicity scope conservatism
can be used to lim to delineate between
theories that make the same predictions
it's called inference to the best
explanation indeed
it seems that a theory accurately
describing reality
is the best explanation for why it's
able to make successful predictions
the reason assuming the world is round
works for navigation
is because the world is round the reason
that treating subatomic particles as
waves predicts their behavior so
accurately
is because they are waves but this still
leaves us with the problem
if the realist is right then subatomic
particles are waves until they are
measured
at which time they collapse down into
particles with particular properties
okay but how does a measurement do this
and why does it collapse a wave function
in one way rather than another
this is famously known as the
measurement problem
according to physicist hugh everett iii
what happens is this
when you make a measurement of a wave
function you don't collapse it
you become part of it literally
to account for what your observation
does you have to plug yourself
in as a variable into the quantum wave
equation you might say that like
lieutenant wharf
you are put in a state of quantum flux
but since according to realists quantum
wave functions represent the way the
world is
that must mean that you are now in a
superposition
just like the wave function so you have
multiple
contradictory properties at once you are
in a state of having observed
the particle both here and there
but how can that be since you are only
aware
of one of those outcomes it must be if
it argues
that observing the wave function splits
you
in two so that there's another version
of you
that observes the other outcome another
you
in another universe so on this
interpretation
the measurement of quantum events causes
alternate
universes of course
wave functions can collapse in the
absence of measurements too
but anytime they do every possible
outcome of that collapse
is realized in a separate universe
when it comes to location there could
actually be more than two
bryce dewitt who later endorsed and
developed this interpretation
once suggested every quantum transition
taking place on every star
in every galaxy in every remote corner
of the universe
is splitting our local world into
myriads of copies of itself
again as data says for any event there
is an infinite number of possible
outcomes
but there is a theory in quantum physics
that all possibilities that can happen
do happen in alternate quantum realities
if this theory is right we live in a
multiverse
and it's getting bigger all the time
physicist lee smolin makes a similar
suggestion
instead of quantum collapses generating
new universes
black holes do so as he explains it
according to general relativity a star
that collapses into a black hole
should squeeze down into an infinite
density and time should
stop within it but quantum forces could
defer this causing the black hole to
merely collapse to a certain extreme
density
and then bounce back and begin to expand
again
and that expanding star becomes the
birth of a new
universe smolin says the point where
time
ends inside a black hole becomes joined
to the point where time begins in a big
bang
in a new universe if the laws that
govern the universe in which the black
hole is formed
influence the kinds of laws that the new
universe will have
you might end up with a kind of natural
selection
where universes that produce black holes
are more likely to
reproduce and thus are more common in
the multiverse
since such laws are also conducive to
life a multiverse created by the
formation of black holes
could be teeming with life living in a
wide variety of scenarios
if the histories of such universes don't
just repeat it would seem that there is
a universe for almost
every way human history could have
turned out
so there actually could be a universe
where the equivalent of german nazis
did win world war ii like in the man in
the high castle
[Music]
some thinkers like paul steinhardt and
george ellis
have argued against the multiverse
suggesting that such theories
are not testable if so the argument goes
they are not scientific and thus not
worthy of taking seriously
but there are essentially three things
to say in response
first a theory being non-scientific
doesn't mean that it's false
so even if steinhardt and alice are
right a multiverse is still at least
possible and if it's possible it's at
least worth considering
second again as we've discussed
elsewhere testability
is not the only factor of scientific
reasoning
if any of the multiverse theories are
more wide scoping
simple and conservative than their
competitors it's not
crazy to think that they're true take
the multiverse interpretation of quantum
mechanics
although it's not simple because it
supposes the existence of
many universes it is the only major
interpretation of quantum mechanics that
doesn't defy
current physical laws by say suggesting
that information can
travel faster than light or backwards in
time so
it may be the only theory that is
actually
conservative and third
some of these multiverse theories are
testable proponents of the bulk brain
multiverse theory long have suspected
that brains floating in the bulk
might occasionally bump into each other
we've also wondered whether two bubble
universes could form
close enough to each other to touch the
effects of such an interaction could be
observable from within the universes
themselves
for example they might leave a
fingerprint on each universe's cosmic
microwave background radiation
physicist rory mckenzie has even
suggested
that the best explanation for a large
cold spot in our universe's microwave
background radiation
could be outside interference from
another universe
smolin has also made predictions to
confirm his black holes theory if he's
right
neutron stars should never be heavier
than two solar masses
and we've never found one that is our
observations of the cosmic background
radiation
are also consistent with the version of
cosmic inflation
that his theory requires cosmologist max
tegmark
has suggested that it's actually the
arguments against
the multiverse that are on thin ice to
suggest that ours is the
only universe seems to endorse the
rather hubristic and unjustified
assumption
that the totality of physical reality
must be observable
by us humans and understandable by us
that if we can't see or understand it
then it just must not be there
of course our not seeing it is also not
evidence that it is there
he may be confusing where the burden of
proof lies on existential matters
but still there is at least some
rhetorical force to this argument
do we really think that all of existence
lies within our perceptual and cognitive
abilities
at the very least the suggestion that
there is a multiverse is not as
crazy as it initially seems after all is
it really
crazy to think that there's a universe
in which we chose a blue background for
this course
will we one day be traveling to such
universes
it might depend on what kind of
multiverse we live in conceptually
it might seem that travel in a bulk
multiverse like in sliders
would be easier than in an oscillating
one
then again to travel in his oscillating
multiverse
all professor farnsworth had to do was
invent a forward time machine
and as we've discussed forward time
travel is
actually possible could diving into a
black hole
get us to one of smolin's alternate
universes could we visit
other quantum realities probably not
such things likely aren't possible and
even if they were
the necessary technology is probably
forever beyond us
but just like when we discuss the
possibility of intergalactic travel
our theories may be wrong or our current
imagination
too stunted we are pretty lousy at
predicting the future
so although i wouldn't bet on it i won't
say i'm certain it'll never happen
that no one will ever trade places with
their counterparts
in other quantum universes like
lieutenant wharf
in parallels but the ending of parallels
raises another interesting question
there at the end you see multiple
wharves in the shuttlecraft
all roaming around are those all
the same person or are they different
persons
all named lieutenant wharf
are beardo spock and regular spock the
same person
or do they just look and act alike like
twins or doppelgangers we might call
this the question of
trans universe identity
to discuss the issues of personal
identity this question raises
i want to discuss a movie called dark
city
as you watch ask yourself would
acquiring someone else's memories
change who you are not just the kind of
person you
are but would it turn you into someone
else would you cease to exist and
someone else
come into existence
see you on the other side
[Music]
[Music]
you